hey you came back thank you so much it's
good to see you again right last episode
we learned a lot about Peter Parker and
his alter-ego spooderman we know that
we're going to be evicted soon we know
that we still have a massive crush on
Mary Jane and we know that there is
something called The Devil's breath
which I think targets people by their
DNA a super weapon if you may and to top
it all off we once again saw Mary Jane
and we realize how much we love that
little ginger nut and we have another
first date and that's where we're going
to pick things up go on Peter make the
first move so I didn't mix become
Italian no idea but I just took go ahead
mix these fries totally best in the city
so how's the grind at the bugle well
yeah well I just got an all caps text
from Robbie about my so-called antics
tonight so it looks like I'll be meeting
with a legal team again as soon as he
reads the article you're gonna write
guaranteed promotion what us move talk I
know we'd be mask guys what's your take
just another night in the city it's your
take I feel like there's bigger story
there well it's not make it's all about
business
how's it going with you did did you get
that promotion
no but we're on the cusp of something
really big you know ask corporate hi are
you in a heartbeat right one phone
called a hairshirt but dr. octavius's
work will help millions I'm right where
I wanna be right where I should be
almost sounds like it's more important
than your other job I've never heard you
talk like that before when I can change
in six months
why did you ask me here Pete you know
just uh just dinner between friends
friends is that what we are I mean who
could be you know you that's what you
wanted
there's a lot of baggage here yeah sure
but is that so bad I mean baggage can
carry good things too like like money
and keys raspberry lip balm do you
remember why we broke up
this is a trick question isn't it yeah
say by the battle run run run Saint by
the siren clothes later go go come on do
it
I love that guy
boom $200 expensive chip loves seeing
you two together again
Oh always were my favorite Stanley water
legend you you I do it always my fight
nope we can't do the accent so I will
stuff that it sounded like I was from
East London who are we chasing down now
usually get a message from the police
officer that likes us if she is hey
what's with the unit's heading down
third my girlfriend Herman Schultz said
it again
Herman shocker didn't he just get
paroled yeah well it didn't take no
worries Herman's just a big cupcake 11
back in Rikers by bedtime
I love fights in this joker just test
dinner with my ex after saving her from
mass criminals and now I'm gonna go beat
up a maniac who uses shockwaves to rob
people what a perfectly normal life you
have Peter Parker Peter you have a
better life than most of us let's get
there
oh look at the lights it's so beautiful
a break-in is reportedly in progress
incident and act is near time we're
proceed with caution
when we're not getting into this we are
going straight to fight Herman the
Shocker let's see him where is the Beast
[Music]
hi Herman seriously what are we doing
Herman
oh we're chasing one another okay get
high get high don't hit the ground
Khushi go see the pressures getting to
me
get high Oh calm down here we go right
in the rhythm of things now let's go
into there
I'm done talking but this could be so
much more rewarding if we connected on
an emotional level how do they talk to
each other if the fifty meters away
through explosions a pretty sermon miss
dragon in African first time now let's
talk something has got him scared come
on
why are you robbing again you know the
police are watching your every move
I don't know you're kind of dumb but I
didn't think you were this dumb you must
be desperate which means you're not just
stealing for yourself must be working
with someone or for someone just tell me
who it is now or make me punch it your
choice
stop running Herman Utah what the hell
whoa he has those shock attacks okay
so we need to keep our wits about us we
another one coming
Oh No stop running Herman I'm sick of
chasing you we're almost there now he's
a ground-level ground-and-pound coming
up dodge that Herman
oh dude look is so so cool no match for
my webs
that's like zero personality but your
suit is awesome
can we talk design details maybe later
just leave him in the street don't tell
anyone no one will notice
good work spider-man did you learn
anything about his motive Linda you
beautiful tried but he's not very
talkative plus I think he hates me you
have that effect on a lot of he does
doesn't he but you love me right Yuri I
tolerate you she loves you do you know
that might be the nicest thing you've
ever said to me
nicely done so I'm sure we'll see the
Shocker multiple times
looks like I got some free time maybe
now's a good time to look into that mask
oh it's MJ hey MJ you're up late shocker
tonight
yeah we did it was unusually combative
anyway thanks again for dinner what do I
owe you
yeah I'm actually on my way to the feast
centre now to ask Martin Lee about it
Marty why he has a degree in art history
course he does if anyone knows about the
origins of that mask he will yeah let's
just walk straight in and walk straight
in with we are spider-man with ghostly
Peter Parker almost morning mr. Lee
he'll be here soon
that could use a snack I almost blew it
all the spider-man doing his free time
he goes on tinder and eats a bagel
my hero
Peter a Martin I knew for you I'm sorry
to bother you mr. Lee
I have a friend Mary Jane she's a
reporter she's doing a story on art
imports and she found this piece well
she wanted an expert opinion on it and I
know you have a degree and this might be
the first time I actually get to use it
let's see what you have I got this bad
boy King interesting
where's she finding I'm really not sure
well what is it a replica of an antique
Chinese well he says demon inside look I
haven't seen one in years demon this
symbol here roughly translates to demon
oh my father read me ghost stories with
that mask and symbol in him when I was
young scared the hell out of me
Peter listen that mask it's it could be
connected to dangerous people you see
warning us Mary Jane might want to find
a different story what do you think
she's in trouble I don't know
why take the risk he's definitely
warning us you stay out of this boy I
take you down I think it's time for a
new suit what do you say
this suit is fantastic but we need
something different suits let's see what
we've got we have the advanced suit the
standard suit the one with rips in it
it's pretty cool
there's no no our suit that looks nice
there's the Scarlet Spider I like that
unaffordable at the present though or
else we have the spider armor Mach 2
unaffordable we can't wear that yet
secret war skin nice I like it a lot
what about spider punk this is the first
one we actually can wear which is
different yeah let's do this
for future reference we have two others
we can use but for now we're going to
use this new superpower to which it
plays guitar it's going to be insane
let's do this Daniel how cool does this
look right what should we do oh there's
a photo thing here how does this work
you press up on the d-pad and that
brings up our instructions our camera
frame it up top lovely you have a
landmark unlocked nice anyway 700 meters
away is our next mission
right back to work we go just dressed as
spider-man okay let's go to work dressed
as spider-man oh I've got changed I
walked through the door and instantly
got changed because I'm Peter parkour
walks like handled swats Anika Octavius
industries I'm ready to do some work I
hope it's like last day of work which
was 12 seconds long how does it work
just like a natural arm you think of
what you want it to do and go for it
dude go for it dude I hope he doesn't
crush the Cup
softly what a legend yes hey oh no hey
oh no you're doing what's going on the
site's been declared a safety hazard a
safety hazard stop that right now this
is highly sensitive equipment that's it
I'm calling the mayor's office directly
Peter Parker how the hell are you speak
of the devil oh please how long have we
known each other
it's mr. mayor it's Norman no Norman
what do you think you're doing here the
grant agreement you signed has strict
safety provisions this isn't your first
violation those who are excused
by me we should have confiscated this
equipment long ago but but I've had a
breakthrough thank you for your great
service to our country these folks will
escort you to a skort robotics where
you'll receive the latest in prosthetics
no charge
this isn't about safety infractions is
it I'm trying to help you Otto
no he's not free to continue your work
ya son of a [ __ ] in a secure
environment at Oscorp you always were
the smartest guy in the room you haven't
changed a bit neither of you yeah
he's got less half hey Peter hey Harry
will be coming back from Europe early
next year maybe the tube you can start
that business you always talked about
this is opportunity knocking didn't well
so he just took some things and left
others it's okay just keep going
put better locks on the door he's easy
easy
they didn't take everything maybe we
could start over Peter there's no we
without the grant from the city I can no
longer pay you I need some time to think
yes you better pay me if I were you I'd
look for a new job McDonald's spider-man
shocker has a stake and now he's robbing
a bank on even 31st he's roping
abandoned I thought he was behind bars
he was but one of the guards just walked
up to his cell and released him then
gave him his suit back I knew Shakur was
working for someone what did you get out
of the guard wish I could ask him but
he's dead release shocker didn't want
any loose and never kill anyone in these
games looking at the security footage
the guard was in some kind of trance and
it might have been the lighting but it
looked like his eyes were glowing
well that's creepy okay I'll see what I
can get out of shocker when I get to the
bank almost there my cool dude
good eye well this in real life though
baby to know
all units at 34 all reported no not
getting involved in any assaults got my
own assault to tend to sound like
they've quietly established a power base
in the Bachelorette by Fisk a vacuum I
created by putting Fisk away Jameson was
right demons are my fault what were you
supposed to do let this keep god
fathering hurry up mg you sound he can
mope your than usual I think I might
have just lost my job the city
Norman actually pulled our funding oh
I'm sorry if Harry were here he could
talk some sense into his dad he'll find
another source report thanks MJ jeez
enjoyed you soon get lost please cuz I
want to fight the shotgun Herman
long time no see hey I'm no lawyer but
I'm pretty sure that's a parole
violation
you ain't going nowhere for a while want
to play 20 questions
know how much face punch it is
yeah this is what we want whoa your
gauntlets are all digital now aren't
they have it your way you wanna fight
we can talk science remember our first
fight right how does this guitar soloing
battle don't get penis Eastern
coming your way in your face bro you
come clean I can help you not gonna
happen
too close too close how do we get out of
that rude boy no people don't use banks
anymore you're lucky you found natural
cash if you really want to rob banks
tried a trailer it's all the rage
it's too strong now
bloody shut graves so if he talks he
will be killed by whomever's isn't
paying him um speaking of dead I'm
almost dead runaway cow hi I'm Jess ah
spider-man
nope nah spider-man ok we know we're
doing this up why do I get [ __ ] first
time they made that very clear
okay here we go it's gonna hurt come on
Hammond I know your routine now have one
of those dialing so he's being employed
by the people in masks so the same ones
that we saw in the auction house know
this fight is more even than I expected
right whilst the shocking [ __ ] when
we hit
you know now we can protect you no way
you son of a beach okay so I still is on
the roof how do we pull those down
without being hit oh my word I need
start dodging one tell
all just fall just older stuff push him
we were lucky that one help brought this
on yourself literally easy this time
okay second time these load screens are
fantastic he was scared and desperate
these demons are everywhere all of a
sudden
lovely looks I need some spandex in my
life
okay Yuri shuckers all yours now good
work we have a special spell waiting for
him in the raft
we'll make sure he stays behind bars
this time also I'm pretty sure he was
working for the demon gang demon gang
sounds like a Daily Bugle headline hey
the bugle is a perfectly fine news
organization I'm not sure I'd call it
the news well I've heard they have some
really good reporters anyway have you
had any more reports on demon guys with
masks let me get back to you by the way
how much of a mess did you make inside
that Bank you probably don't want to
know
thanks URI see you next time ballon
fight with Shakur took a while time to
catch up on what I've been missing out
in the city that's great news
well this plan works we shall swing
until your he gets back in touch with
our next mission hey so I looked into
reports of demons I knew you'd come
around they've been pretty busy tonight
hitting a lot of fish properties they're
going after fish
damn you thinking what I'm thinking
let's try to get ahead of it
are there any fist properties that
haven't been hit tonight let me see yeah
patrol reported a bunch of activity at
one of his shipyards in portside thanks
you're eating I'll check it out we're
now way 300 meters oh I have an idea we
haven't tried something yet something
which ruins every single open-world game
on an island
do you know what's going to happen we're
going swimming Oh can't swim or have I
triggered a cutscene I seriously have no
idea what we're doing good scene
cutscene so he comes with like the bomb
if I'll have your head got it boss
tripling security demons won't touch a
thing
listen up demons are making moves on all
our caches lost to tonight already boss
maybe in lockup
that don't mean his hardware's up for
grabs come chicky go to you up Eagle two
reporting in
I saw what caches are the demons after I
need to take out Fisk's men and figure
out what they're guarding whatever it is
I don't want it in Fisk's or the demons
hands snipers everywhere
I need a we have to her stealth gameplay
who is the highest one up there near the
water tower so we'll work round go for
him first
spider stealth spiders down for the
spiders delft does this is how we do it
yeah it's actually quite difficult to
see even though he's red hello yeah a
local Avon representative lovely place
to put him
oh how cute is that so right right when
when this dissolves he's just going to
fall to his death isn't he poor guy
right who's next the guy on the far
warehouse or the guy in front of us
can we get around to him you Billy hello
sir
please have a nice rest I'll suffocate
you with Webb's next yeah back to the
one on the warehouse I think that's the
best one to go for
creepy creepy that's so good it sounds
like the rest of them are in toons
that sniper has a guard watching him we
need to divide and conquer no but don't
Spidey we just need to make them into
lovely decorations Oh gorgeous
- that worn on his own that - over there
there's two to the right
it's too very far away and is one bottle
epic so we'll start with him on the left
we'll stick you up here you've got
company there though for the guy stuck
there with you so you're not alone it's
too low this is too low who can see me
run away we can secure the last gear
hmm one of them has found a dead body
Oh wrong button I don't think that
counts has been seen as long as we get
him straight away nice pinata for
someone to use they must notice that
it's right in the face don't question it
it's fine
come join your friends we'll see how
many pinatas we can put in a row
who's next in the pinata thong we'll
just tie him up here
come over here dude you need to join the
pinata brothers
Hey three in a row gorgeous
Hey look at those three - oh no
somebody's seen me run away we could
have had it man
no iciness Oh No okay the fighting
begins we did okay get back down
sweep it off can't see me spider stealth
at its greatest good night sir
awesome really enjoyable
we got a qapla will it be a horrible
mean copper will it be a lovely
policeman doing his job you know we
can't have vigilantes trust passing or
doing illegal searches yeah I know which
is why I brought a wart what a guy so
what do you say we do some perfectly
legal searching sounds good boss I like
the sound of that
what's your name obviously Davis call me
Jeff Jeff you are just messing with you
what sons a big fan so that won't cover
breaking down doors not without a lot of
extra paperwork okay I'll find another
way in easy Ben go any place this
rundown should have a hole in the wall
right broken window we use the one on
the back instead easy peasy
I feel like I'm in a horror movie whoa
hello
the fisherman with a grudge and a hook
for an this reminds me of heavy rain
okay where's that locked door well we
find John John Rose ex DeSean
let's let Jeff in Jeff you there yeah
I'm doing my best to refrain from
knock-knock jokes yes
yeah got it
smart but I don't have anything that
packs enough current guitar Oh sir yes
stun gun electric guitar should have
worked for an upgrade I've been thinking
half the pallets I've been playing too
much fortnight's I wanted to break the
pallets okay let's craft stun webs can I
presume we just shoot that thing with it
back in action electric wehmanen Jeff
gadget man huh you remind me of my son
started taking apart the TV when he was
five
now he's unlocking his friends phones
talk to me son of loss sounds like he
could teach me a few things you think
his son's miles no he can't be he's not
called Officer Morales he's in plain
sight can i anti-climactic huh at first
glance
let's look closer it's look closer dude
looking for something specific this
yards been here a long time bootleggers
used to use it back in the day gotcha
those guys love their hidden rooms
check it out sound hollow do you know I
can't hit it doesn't sound off got a
hidden panel like the one on the door
you found a hidden panel that quickly
you should be spider-man not me let's
see if my mask lenses can pick up the
conduit found a bus
- ooh dude oh there's something in the
way one down that work nobody saw that
mistake pretend I did it on purpose
founded bus business oh hey I doubt I
would have found it without you
yes you are the real superhero here Jess
I got a big fat nothing
well there's one secret room that could
be more notice anything about the floor
scrunch they can hide the doors but they
can't have this crazy stretchy stuff on
the filling out four more of those okay
I'll find one straight - wait I found
some I found some scratchy scratch jeez
officer Jeff where else could there be
scrapes pay dirt scrape no door none I
can see anyway okay take your time
Hey look at these sneakers sit tight
I'll pull you up I can fix the elevator
for you sir just not that second floor
rusted machine parts big hunk of rats
careful the bridge is out
I got this one nice stuck the landing
and everything we're not all donut
eaters fair enough another secret door
I'll rig the lock let me know if you
find the junction box yep on it
[Music]
that one right deal let them coming back
to you let's open this bad boy hey check
this out
nothing I'm starting to feel like this
is fiscal way of messing with me look at
the walls
they kept guns here they wouldn't really
interested in you saying man gotta be a
bad interesting
check out the wall I wouldn't want to
put you off bet on it looks like a dual
circuit see if we can find a second okay
junctions I'm on it dude one down that
that's not it
everydays over hit up behind that but
it's blocked what do we do for a
junction box where would I be I'm
already here we need to move be whatever
this is it's a lift
it's a lift all we do is shoot up there
we are sorted oh you were right Jeff
trapdoor secret basement
outstanding thank you no me out this
thing's heavy
you'd be you're Jeff you can do anything
Jeff go on Jeff you can do a house done
here go Jeff
[Music]
No okay I'll help just this one one two
three
well that isn't spooky at all probably
an old bootleggers tunnel and it looks
like no one's cleaned it since Al Capone
[Music]
big chunk of concrete in the way I can't
get through
let me see how it looks from the top
from the top get on the roof get on the
roof I'm stuck
how do I get up there we go that's how
you get on the roof
got room to maneuver here hang on
I'll block anything you can do what was
that
so boy maybe okay the real subway no the
real news and that sounds like demons
vault
hurry what a way to hustle here we go
timing there's a vault here let's find
the vault come on Jeff you're my new
favorite superhero Jeff man damn demons
are already gone how'd they beat us here
see if you can find it
nobody's taken everything one of an
armory they have taken we're missing
something Jeff there must be something
here there they blew the locks to get it
alright the door yeah Adolphe we found
them
yes shout shush yeah that's the greatest
thing to do shush stay here
hell no it'll take both of us to stumble
here Jeff and some of these are the
power of my webs find cover
let's do this let's get some fighting
death row I'm talking about that chick
webs are pretty cool too down who's next
Jeff is bloody genius Jeff you really
are so good to have a round smoked Bobby
people we have rock and roll powers if
we need them how I see I hope Jeff is
playable okay I'll stop messing around
do timing is impeccable lost him Jeff
what did you do to him
Jeff where is she look at this guy see
I've got friends too why aren't you
hitting me he's dumb Jeff you won that
fight all on your own
rock'n'roll get out of the way of that
shut up crime it's a new man on the
block and his name is Jeff get the one
with the shield please Jeff I couldn't
finish this guy with these inside there
oh I thought we were good setting on
fire in the first row Jeff you are a
low-life one laughs Jeff we're done
the new team of Japan and spider-man
thanks Jeff see you soon mate
all right let's keep close by these two
trucks full of gunmen in one day it's
time to hang up the webs
we get on top
what the heck is next
you can't hit me you can't see me
now did that on purpose if anybody asks
[Music]
not much better this guy's all over the
world someone if I can't stop I really
need to catch up
stay safe Jeff don't do anything crazy
see you soon Jeff
let me aboard your vehicle
getting closer with those here we go I
stand before get shot I gotta get in hi
everyone what you doing okay okay get
out of it you can't eat me you can't
even go and you need to leave sir
hey how are you doing
I'm coming visit Anka coming
I wouldn't
I just let him die just let go look at
my muscles
are we gonna do we're gonna die yes man
the hero that is Jeff man
what a guy what a guy
come on everybody clap at this guy he's
a genius
Jim man we've now identified the officer
as Jefferson Davis we're being told he
has minor injuries and is expected to
make a full recovery
excuse me miss are you supposed to be
here more than you
after that auction house thing the bugle
put me on the city beat which means I
get to focus full-time on real stories
like this and the demons you know the
closer you get to them the more you
become a target right
the closer I get the better chance we
have to stop them we meet we're a team
like a boyfriend anyway mr. Davis Mary
Jane Watson Daily Bugle no coming I
don't blame you but these guys are gonna
tell their story with or without you and
they thrive on controversy so what
searing I don't have one I just listen
okay up in hop on I'll paint very very
different
she's good meter Jeff is making a move
on your girlfriend okay there we have it
what do you think I think we should stop
there
episode 2 done and dusted Jefferson
Davis is my hero what a guy he is I hope
he's part of this story for much longer
and it sounds like he might be miles is
dad but we won't go into that until next
time anyway it's been an absolute
pleasure I've really enjoyed this oh
we've got fast travel points now oh
we're going up in the world right I'll
see you soon I might have from
PlayStation grenade peace out more folks
[Music]